AN IMPORTANT VOICE BUT I THINK
YOU ARE WRONG ON SOME DETAILS.
>> HAVE ME BACK.
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: WITH SMART PHONES
EVERYWHERE IN EVERY POCKET IS
IT POSSIBLE TO ESCAPE SELFIES
IN EVERYBODY GETS ROPED IN, IT
TURNS OUT.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN FOR THE REST
OF US.
THE PRESIDENT DOES IT.
POPE FRANCIS DOES IT.
WELL, NOW, SOME RESEARCHERS
ARE CALLING THIS A DISEASE.
FEW PEOPLE REPORT BEING
HELPLESSLY ADDICTED TO TAKING
PHOTOS OF THEMSELVES SO THEY
SNAP HUNDREDS OF SELFIES EVERY
DAY.
THEY ARE SIMPLY UNABLE TO
STOP.
IS THERE MORE DISGUSTING
ILLNESSES IN THE WORLD?
PROBABLY NOT.
WE'RE JOINED BY A
PSYCHOTHERAPIST.
NEL, IT DEGRADES SCIENCE TO
CALL IT AN ILLNESS WHEN IT'S
SELF-INVOLVEMENT OF A KIND
WE'RE FAMILIAR WITH.
WE HAVE REACHED A GREATER
MAGNITUDE.
>> I KNOW THAT IS IF GUT
REACTION AND I SEE WHY YOU
WOULD SAY THAT.
BUT I THINK THERE IS A BIG
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THINKING
THAT SOMEONE IS NARCISSISTIC
AND THEY POST SELFIES ALL THE
TIME BECAUSE THEY SUFFER FROM
AN ELEMENT OF NARCISSISM AND
ACTUAL ADDICTION.
SO WHEN YOU HAVE WHAT IS CITED
IN THIS STUDY WAS A BUNCH OF
YOUNG WOMEN CONSTANTLY TAKING
SELFIES OF EACH OTHER YOU HAVE
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE DEVICES
ARE ADDICTIVE.
I DON'T NECESSARILY THINK AND
IT HASN'T BEEN PROVEN THAT IT
COMES FROM A PLACE NECESSARILY
FROM A NARCISSISTIC PLACE.
>> Tucker: REALLY?
>> YEAH.
>> Tucker: SO IF YOU FIND
OUR OWN FACE THE MOST
INTERESTING IMAGE IN THE
WORLD, THAT IS NOT
SELF-INVOLVEMENT?
IT SEEMS LIKE IT TO ME.
>> I KNOW BUT ACTUALLY THINK
ABOUT IT, TUCKER.
WOULDN'T YOU THINK IF THAT IS
HOW YOU ARE SPENDING YOUR TIME
AND IT IMPAIRS YOUR DAILY
FUNCTION IT'S COMING FROM A
PLACE OF MAYBE PERHAPS LOW
SELF-ESTEEM?
SO WE ARE FLOODED ALL THE
TIME -- THESE DEVICE,
UNDERSTAND INSTAGRAM AND
FACEBOOK, ALL THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS ARE BUILT TO BE
REALLY ADDICTIVE.
AND YOU CAN'T TALK TO ANY
MARKETING OR P.R. AGENCY THAT
DOESN'T SAY IF YOU ARE TRYING
TO BUILD A BRAND OR A BUSINESS
THAT YOU SHOULDN'T POST
PICTURES OF YOURSELF.
THAT IS THE MESSAGE WE ARE
SENDING CONSTANTLY.
THE GREATEST POPULATION ON
INSTAGRAM, FOR EXAMPLE, ARE
YOUNG WOMEN BETWEEN THE AGES
OF 18 AND 25.
WHAT THEY LOOK AT THE MOST IS
MAKEUP AND FASHION.
WE ARE ATTRACTED TO PEOPLE'S
FACES.
THAT IS A BIG DIFFERENCE, THAT
IS A LITTLE BIT OF A DIFFERENT
TALKING ABOUT YOUNG WOMEN OR
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUPER ADDICTED
TO TAKING SELFIES.
UNFORTUNATELY, SELFIES MAKE
MONEY.
IF YOU LOOK AT INSTAGRAM AT
ALL YOU WILL SEE THAT THERE IS
TONS OF PEOPLE MAKING MONEY BY
POSTING VIDEOS OF THEMSELVES,
FOR EXAMPLE, PUTTING ON MAKEUP
OR DOING, YOU KNOW, DIFFERENT
EXERCISES AND SHOWING PEOPLE
HOW TO DO THAT.
>> Tucker: ASK YOU A QUICK
QUESTION.
THE FEMINIST LONG THAT IS DUMB
AND WRONG AS USUAL.
BUT DUMBER IS THE MOST MEN ARE
THE CAUSE OF THAT.
THEY ARE ADDING TO THE SUM
TOTAL OF UNHAPPINESS FOR YOUNG
WOMEN AND NO ONE CALLS THEM
OUT ON THAT.
WHY IS THAT?
>> Sean: THE FIRST PART OF
THE COMMENT I'M NOT SURE I
AGREE WITH I DON'T THINK ALL
FEMINISTS BELIEVE IT'S JUST
MEN CAUSING WOMEN TO HAVE LOW
SELF-ESTEEM.
>> Tucker: THE ONES THAT
COME ON TV SAY THAT.
>> OKAY.
I'M A FEMINIST AND I DON'T SAY
THAT.
HERE IS THE THING.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THESE DEVICES
AND I AGREE WITH YOU THAT
FACEBOOK AND INSTAGRAM NEED TO
HAVE SORT OF A BIGGER ETHICAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO CREATE
PLATFORMS THAT DON'T
NECESSARILY PUSH PEOPLE ALWAYS
HAVING TO POST THEIR FACE ON
THE PLATFORM TO BE SUPER
ADDICTIVE.
I AGREE.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
THE IMAGES ARE OWNED BY THE